[Applaudissements]
cette année il ya un mot bien sûr qui a
été un mot fétiche c'est le mot chocolat
dont vous aviez des pas énormes attentes
ça y est c'est vrai que ça a été notre
nouveau délire en cette fin de saison
je crois que c'est presque un record
c'est une séquence qui a tenu plus de
trois mois
donc j'ai pris mon pays est la raison
trois mois ce que vous dites vous dit
notre délire c'est banal notre délire
cas nous sommes une équipe
voilà je vous le dis on danse ensemble
on sort ensemble on mange ensemble on
meurt ensemble non merci
jonathan sans merci on a pas tous le
même âge mais bon dieu 2,3 allez-y
[Musique]
quand
sol
comme impur
regardez ce qui s'est passé après
non
[Applaudissements]
vous avez quelqu'un qui disait dans la
choucroute parents vous vous lisez dans
quoi alors écoutez j'ai d'autres
supports effectivement comme le chocolat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon chéri tu as vu ce qui arrive aux
chroniqueurs total de la crème ouais et
ils ont des chocolats
[Applaudissements]
ce jour là
[Musique]
on a reçu vanille et c'est vrai qu'à un
moment je me suis dit pourquoi on reçoit
pas chocolat
[Applaudissements]
et oui vous êtes sessions dites vous
qu'en d'autres temps ci sont retrouvés
une dentellière aux reflets chocolat
[Musique]
quand
[Applaudissements]